we do have some breaking news for you a
court in Saudi Arabia has sentenced five
people to death for the murder of
Washington Post columnist Jamal
khashoggi Saudi state TV says three
others have been given prison time
khashoggi is believed to have been
killed at the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul Turkey in October last year
Charlie d'Agata is following the case
from London Charlie what led to the
sentences that we now know about well
good morning well his shocking murder
last year drew international
condemnation the trial was held in near
total secrecy this morning the Saudi
prosecutor said the five men who were
sentenced to death directly took part in
that killing the prominent Washington
Post columnist and fierce critic of the
Saudi leadership was last seen walking
into the Saudi consulate in Istanbul in
October last year he never walked out
his body allegedly dismembered and
removed the remains were never found
CIA investigators blame the
assassination on Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman although he denies any
involvement but today prosecutors say
the only top aide implicated in the
murder Saud al Kitani was investigated
but not charged and released now trial
may be over but deep suspicions remain
there's long been criticism of the Saudi
government's lack of transparency in
investigating this murder internally
Jericka Charlie d'Agata force in London
thank you
you